what happened to your alma mater why do
I know you bring that up well they ran
into a Gamecock scene that was
determined that is tough and it turned a
lot of they made a lot of turnover and
sort of created a lot of turnovers and
really just played a great game you know
you know Duke didn't couldn't value the
basketball and then they'd give up 65
points in the second half that's just
not good defense by Duke and you have to
tip your hat so on well notice silver
dolger all those kids played they played
great and and they deserve to advance to
the sweet 16 I noticed that you have
teams that have the ability to close out
other teams in the tournament that and I
don't know what it comes down to if if
you've been in the moment if it's
seniors or juniors but we saw some teams
who could and some teams who couldn't
what is it about that in that final
minute of an NCAA Tournament game where
it comes down to being in the moment in
understanding what you need to do and
you know what you need to avoid I was in
Indianapolis this past weekend in
Michigan you know something really
special is going on with that team and
how they have played how they've you
know they have a spirit about them they
have a confidence of trust and they just
make the right plays down the stretch
gonna get stops they get blocks there's
turnovers and they're able to have God
step up on the offensive end so it's
hard to put into words what that is or
what makes that or what the ingredient
is for that kind of success but they are
an experienced team you got guys like
Derrick Walton and Rahman and Ervin and
they've been battle tested and in Wilson
and vogner or capable players who have
experience as well so you know look last
year Villanova you know the team that
didn't have a superstar
didn't have a NBA draft pick from last
year first-round draft pick but they
have a collective relief collective
confidence of collective toughness that
allowed them to you know have a great
tournament and ultimately went the close
game down switch you got a chance see
Kentucky against which its own state
it's almost as if Kentucky's a little
bit of an underdog here do you get that
feeling that we're not talking about
Kentucky the way we talked about some of
these other teams here yeah kind of
weird you know I mean Kentucky there
were a lot of fans there in Indianapolis
and you know Kentucky is a very talented
team but I think history you know from
2013 wichita state coming up short and
you know wichita state having a great
season maybe being you know incorrectly
seated i don't think they were MC yeah
and and this having great depth you know
there was a feeling that wichita state
we're going to win that game and they
played well and played hard but you know
we talked about experience we talked
about closing out games well the
freshman of kentucky yesterday did a
magnificent job malik monk who kind of
has struggled as of late hits in a big
shot they got some great stops and of
course the Aaron Fox who's sensational
so they did a great job I mean that to
me and there's one coach who can get
those young guys ready about the regular
season for the postseason is John
Calipari so as impressive I was of
Michigan and their ability I was also
impressed with Kentucky closing out
against the very tough Wichita State een
talking to Grant Hill you got North
Carolina Butler coming up in Kentucky
UCLA who does long so ball remind you of
really you know Jason you know didn't
have the jump shot
you know at that young of an age but I
just love his ability to make others
better
he just the kind of guy that I think
guys want to play them he just you know
the ball moves it becomes contagious
they move the ball around and share it
he's so explosive he just plays
basketball the right way and he can
dominate a game without scoring and of
course we know he can't score you know
we know he's got great range he's a
great athlete he's his has a skill you
can tell that he didn't just work out
and train and do the drills but he
played a lot because he had that special
quality it's his great instincts that
you really can't teach I wanted to hit
on this topic since you being a former
NBA player all-star and covering the NBA
is there anything the Commissioner can
do about these star players sitting out
games as we saw recently with what
happened with the Cavs against the
Clippers well you know it's a great
question I mean I think there's been
much more of an emphasis overall in this
sort of modern era in the NBA of
wresting players and preserving players
and that's not a bad thing I mean shoot
I wish somebody had done that with maybe
some things but and so everything has
been discussed you know we have a longer
all-star break now we start the season a
little bit earlier we have fewer
back-to-back games so I think you know
that that that emphasis has definitely
been there I think you want to be
careful when you start fitting players
like that and I think that's tough I
think the Commissioner and we can take a
look at it I don't know what the
solution is but ultimately I get from a
player standpoint and a team standpoint
particularly a team like Cleveland like
San Antonio like gold state where they
have expectations to be playing in June
and it's a long season and they want to
be fresh and at their best but
ultimately you know fans are the ones
that get shortchanged and the fans are
the ones who you know basically support
this league and make this week what it
is
you talk about all the contracts that
went out last summer and how that will
be even more magnified and increased
this summer coming up the television era
but the league is thriving right now and
that's because of the support of our
fans oh I think you want to be careful I
think also look Commissioner silver
talks about you know they also again you
know what can we do to make that more
competitive more exciting because what
we see in the last few years has not
been fun to watch and once again the
fans are the ones with your short range
have fun coming up this week its North
Carolina Butler Kentucky UCLA Grant Hill
joining us on the program grant good to
talk to you thanks for joining us all
right Dan thank you and make that shot
your commercials that was the third tank
okay I thought you were gonna say one
thing but I appreciate Donna
gotta be honest when it comes to hitting
jumpers there you know like Thank You
grant that's a grand Hill former Dukie
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience